[Music]
yayyy
it's heading your way
it's headed our way that is Christmas
time to buy
Gavin Luke and I don't know who Gavin
Luke is it says I just rent his name off
the internet and that's where I found
his name on the internet so I sound
weird I'm gonna tell you that out the
gate I sound like I have just kind of a
juxtaposition going on with inside of
myself and because that is I am
currently under some general anesthesia
you know and general anesthesia also not
job well anesthesia name of a black girl
that I went to school with growing up
beautiful young lady anesthesia Crandall
but general anesthesia she did not
enlist in the military general
anesthesia is a drug and it's a drug
they give you when you go in for type of
a surgery or outpatient type of a
surgery or procedure and so that's what
happened to me I got procedure eyes I
had to go and get a procedure here's
what here but my problem is I can't
smell that good you would think I got
that snout you know I got that kill of
snout you know I got that face piece and
you would think that that I would be
able to smell you know that be able to
get a hit off of something from you know
you know at least 11 feet away you know
I could smell the berry under a pie
crust and I could call that thing out
that's black that's poison
that's rash but the truth is I can't
smell that good and one of the problems
was I couldn't breathe that good at
night I would lay down at night and I
would not be able to breathe so in all
my dreams I'm not breathing well which
isn't fun because they did your dreams
if you want to have a dream I would find
myself in my dreams go and get an oxygen
tanks and stuff like that you know so
then all my dreams I'm carrying like a
heavy oxygen thing on my back that a
normal person would do if they were
swimming in the ocean or going
underwater looking for shellfish or
looking for you know treasure buried you
know not very but sunken treasure
so I had to go in to get a procedure
where they go in and they have these
things in your inside like the back of
your nose where it hooks into your
skeleton I think this is definitely not
technical information I'm sharing with
you where they they got a they got a G
up your terminates you got turbinates
inside of your face if you ever wonder
you know am i a superhero could I be a
superhero
well I'll tell you right now that
legally by the laws of mother nature and
the Lord you have turbinates in your
face and turbinates are the little parts
that um that like the canals where the
air goes through and it's going back
into your brain so you could get that
hit off the world you know like you
might inhale and you might get 90% air
into your face I inhale I was running
about 25 percent so they had to go in
there and then literally they put you to
sleep and they just they get inside of
your dome and they and they they GU out
you know it is pretty baffling they'll
kind of shave down some areas or orgy up
some other areas you know and I know
that's not technical terminology but
that's what they that's what they did to
me so I didn't have to have any you know
my nose gets is now stopped up with you
know pieces of the inside of my nose and
uh I guess honestly of blood and maybe
plasma I don't know so I'm sorry that
that's how I sound today but that's how
I sound
and there's not anything else that I can
do about it I'm still under some you
know that general anesthesia and and I'm
trying to feel better I feel a little
bit high you know and they hit daddy
with them perks boy they hit daddy with
that 30 pack of percocets and so that
was a little while you know I took half
of one yesterday cuz I got the procedure
yesterday morning and then I'm going to
just give the rest over to I don't know
what I'd do with them if I'm not taking
them I mean I guess they I don't want to
Salim I don't think on the street you
know cuz I'm not trying to be like that
and keep drugs out there but maybe if I
see somebody in pain you know saying
I'll drop one in their mouth you know
hit him with that Christmas spirit hit
him with that little uh hit him with
that Grinch as Tylenol you know that
percocet oh man my nose is backfiring
right now did it it is an R&R but I
appreciate you guys joining me in and
happy Thursday December 14th and thank
you guys for being a part of this past
weekend this is I believe the 53rd
episode so that gets us through an
entire year of episodes it has been
quite a journey and quite a ride and I'm
feeling better a lot of people chimed in
about you know I wasn't feeling very
good last week and and I am feeling
better you know feeling a little subdued
by this by this you know this then the
doctors getting into my snout and you
know Cavor Natan into my face but I'm
gonna be okay
or the rebound from this in a couple
days I'll be smelling again but I'll say
I'll say this it's not fun to eat well
you can't smell everything you put in
your mouth is just a shape or just a
feet just like a it's like maybe warmer
cold or just a shape you know everything
has there's no value to any of it you
know it doesn't have any taste and I
really always thought being blind would
be really tough you know and I have a I
have a friend that's blind and he said
that it's not that bad in there and he's
honestly honest he's really honest dude
and I'm not saying a lot of blind people
aren't honest but there's this whole rap
about blind people that it's horrible
you know that it's miserable in there
it's dark dark dark and then it's you
know people scary there's you know the
winds are always howling it's [ __ ] in
there but my cousin my friend said not
bad not that bad he's also he's kind of
a little bit lazy I think but I mean
he's blind so it's you know six and one
half dozen to the other really but he
said it's not that bad but I always
thought that being blind would be the
toughest thing
to deal with but man I haven't be a tug
blind and being a knows blood which is
when you can't smell our taste
it's heavy it's heavy because everything
you put your mouth it could be anything
you know it has no you know yesterday I
ate two packs of kool-aid powder you
know I hate to direct packs of kool-aid
powder and I took up straight to the
dome because I'm thinking if I can't
taste that this is a time when I can do
things that normally would be I wouldn't
be able to do because the taste would
revolt be you know so I hit that
kool-aid powder and they hit another
flavor couldn't tell the difference we
neither one of them you know you could
take a whole pack of kool-aid powder to
the dome so pretty
I guess interesting I don't know I'll be
honest with the event I'm wavering in
and out with this uh general anaesthesia
and shout out to anaesthesia Crandall
back there anaesthesia but I went in
there so when it's a UCLA medical and
the lady said are you allergic to
anything and I said cocaine maybe a cat
you know I said don't tell it just tell
a doctor not to prescribe 80 grams for
me cuz daddy will be I'll be back you
know I'll be filling that script I'll
turn eight ball into a 16 ball like that
but happy hour December we started off
with a little bit of with Christmas
music there and I got an I got to tell
you guys tiny saying who is coming back
at us next week I hit him up I emailed
him I said tiny I said I we need
something you know we got the holidays
coming up and he sent me a riff it's him
playing jingle bells on his electric
guitar and it's fire and I'm gonna bring
that to you guys next week as well I
wanted to play a call that came in from
a caller about excuse me man a call that
came in from a caller about you know a
issue that I had with the caller's
girlfriend on the road a while back a
wild wild back
you know beginning of the year and I
wanted to play that but I'm just in such
a weird head space today that I'm gonna
play it on Monday when I'm a little bit
more you know fully released from
whatever's going on in my in my face and
skull cuz my skull don't feel right my
skull don't feel my skull feels left if
you know what I'm saying but but what
else we got the holidays coming up we
got tiny saying who hit us with that
hitter it's coming in when I thank gray
block pizza cuz you know they always on
board with them pies get that Italian
pie ooh what's in your mouth oh that
great block put it in your mouth get
daddy a tie so that's something that's
over here in Los Angeles and I wanted to
talk about some of these Christmases you
know they got different Christmases
around the world in Australia they got a
dude named Krampus and this fellow named
Krampus he beats naughty children with
branches he beats naughty children with
branches and we call that basically in
America I'm gonna tell you that we call
that a step daddy we call that a step
daddy and everybody got that step daddy
that's kind of crazy first time you see
that do you like man he got some wild
pants his pants look weird you know the
hair on it you know that's what you
first known as hair on the man's legs we
see a step daddy he wearing shorts to
church man that's a sin yeah dude if I
see somebody with shorts on a church boy
well you might as well pull their card
right there and check the hell box
I can't imagine you going to heaven if
you got winter shorts to church that's a
great I mean that's uh that's definitely
us hell bound behavior I feel like just
my thoughts but that's something
happened in Australia they beat naughty
children with branches they get that
Adrian Peterson oh boy that thousand
yard rusher and that's Krampus but I
like that at least because in America
all you have is Santa you know it's not
like you if saying you either get Santa
or you get Centuria
you know where either Santa shows up or
you know this satanic cult shows up you
know it rearranges your freakin fingers
you know that you know you wake up at
the border your thumb is in the middle
or your head you know and you can't tell
if you hitching a ride or flipping
people off you know I just wish there
was like a double you know another
circus just saying it's gonna come soon
let's not code that's what they say to
children Santa's not coming oh really he
came last year and I was an [ __ ] last
year so I don't know man ah lot going on
in my skull right now in Catalonia in
Catalonia and that is I'm gonna go with
Italian and I would I would wager half
of my money on that Alex I'm gonna go
with Italian in Catalonia nativity
scenes they have something called the
cagin er CA GA in ER and it's a
defecating man it's that deuce man Doo
doos boy you got that do getting shitty
and then a nativity you know and that's
why that really adds an extra edge to
the an extra edge to the whole story you
know you get the three wise men you got
that mad [ __ ] ER in the corner that dude
that's been doing cocaine or had too
much coffee at the bus stop you know
he's over there [ __ ] in a corner of
the scenario that's pretty [ __ ]
gangster when you think about it I gotta
say shout-out to Catalonia man for doing
that cuz that's wild nativity scenes
would be really spiced up if [ __ ] was
you know you you know like say you throw
a dude into one of them that had a grill
some dude that was working a big grill
suddenly the sheep and the the donkey
they got a wild look at their eyes cuz
they're either you know they're trying
to be down with the savior but he's a
new board you know and they don't know
if they'd make it friends with him quick
enough before the the do run in that
grill is gonna spark them up it serve up
some local beats there so that's really
uh that's really something to be
you know something that could happen
that's really something that could have
happened oh I literally cannot breathe
out of my nose at all so y'all just bear
with me man I appreciate you guys for
being here today
where else fool listen to that man every
time I swallow listen to this every time
I swallowed my nose makes like a funny
noise hold on and in that time I didn't
do it in Germany they had a pickle into
Christmas tree on Christmas Eve the
first child to get it find it gets a
small gift and a German and that's wow
that's wild to think about two Germans
hunting pickles you know I don't know if
that seems really German I seemed Kutta
I seemed a little bit homoerotic you
know you had a couple cucumbers you know
you had a couple Cobras up in a in a
fern at your house
that's that seemed a little bit
homoerotic to me but hey whatever you
know I think it's kind of fun maybe how
to uh you know we still how to put a
chocolate under each other's pillow but
then people forget about it and then you
just get chocolate all in your bed you
know you get chocolate all in your arms
and [ __ ] while you sleep and you try to
sleep and you got chocolate you got new
getting [ __ ] and they used to be
something wild that would happen around
us sometimes what else in the Czech
Republic unmarried women stand by the
door and throw a shoe over their
shoulder if the toe is pointing towards
the door when it lands they will get
married within the next year and I'm
guessing that if that if the toe isn't
pointing towards the door they just
throw it again probably cause who the
[ __ ] wants to be lonely especially out
there in the Czech Republic because it's
probably really cold and you don't be
lonely man because the sex will keep you
warm but playing with yourself just keep
you you know cold and and uh did you
feel a little bit of self appreciation
but you still feel cold you do a little
bit of sex you feel warmed up but if you
just do it self appreciation or self
touch you
feeling anything spectacular if you
still feel kind of cold legged after you
don't spray it out and I think that's
for either gender that's for either
gender right there and I went got this
procedure and I told a man straight up
well before they sent me into the back I
told the man I said you know I don't
want you don't cut my legs off the
mantle there's on the computer these
type of [ __ ] in I said just don't click
on the legs button cuz I'm you know I'm
walking out of here because that happens
you realize that happens people walk it
people imagine you only have one leg you
go to the hospital you're supposed to do
something maybe get a high you know get
an eye taken out or some or you know get
your ear you know get one of the ears
sewed together or something or whatever
and then next thing you know they take
your leg on accident now you can't even
[ __ ] hop you were already down of
just being somebody that hops and now
some idiot who hit the wrong button in
there by the surgery center now you
hopless now if you want to you know you
can't even stand up the best you could
do is just you know sit there on your
thigh on your thigh you know chunks and
tell somebody you're standing up that's
crazy isn't it that you can't even stand
up the best you could do is just keep
yelling I'm standing up even though you
look the same as you always do because
you don't have any lint any legs so you
got to be careful you go into these
centers I tell them straight up I want
to leave here with my legs you know cuz
anything man those [ __ ] in
there all night some of them you know
they got the dude in there the guy that
was put me on an anesthesia with this
gentleman I think was honestly you know
no disrespect at all but I think the
general might have been hoping erotic so
he I don't know how long this dudes put
me down for I don't know if he got a
trunk outside and he trying to be wild
cuz I got a nice ass but it'll be honest
you know I got a nice ass and I just get
worried you know they take your leg
take an eye easily you know you don't
easier I could come out of your head
easily next thing you know you got a
special you you trying to have a [ __ ]
fancy pants or something you try to get
that patch with the flames on it for
summertime or something trying to be
cool at the beach you know you try to
get that Christmas patch where it's like
you know something a little bit of
glitter dust on the outside of it yeah
come on man maybe you start a store
online pats patches and you slanging
patches I mean it's just you got to be
careful you got to be careful out there
man when you go into these surgery
centers you don't know you don't know
what they're gonna do to you that's why
when I go in I tell them straight up I
want to walk out here with my legs I'm
here because my snout needs to get
rocked out a little bit so check my
levels and get in there cuz I'm ready to
change a little but I'm not ready to
change a lot you know I'm standing with
somebody pushing me out of here in a
baby carriage because y'all taking my
legs and all y'all out here [ __ ]
around because dude I've read an article
somewhere they said 15 percent of
America's old drugs now is that
realistic stat probably not dude but it
counts I think you know I guess does it
I don't know Roy Moore almost got
elected you saw that ro mo wah and
that's the name nobody ever knew about
Roy Moore you know he's been in and out
of term over there in Alabama for a
while the Senate and then suddenly you
know it's every political race is now a
big deal you know because there's just
two sides in America and a roy boys case
was interesting because he's a legend
file you know he'd had touch her he got
that long reach you got to have long
arms touch a child that's what my days
and tell me he said look you gotta have
long or such a child and you know and I
never been in any of that dude when I
see a kid all I think about is man this
[ __ ] kid is probably gonna bother me
and I'm grateful that's the only thing I
think but the thing about Roy
or was itwas allege that he was you know
trying to date younger women it was
alleged there were stories from women
there were accusations for sure you know
there was a video also from a a child of
one of the women saying that the woman
was not a truthful woman there was a lot
of stuff out there but you know he was
never he wasn't convicted of anything
he's just accused and uh and I'm not
supporting Roy Moore but I am saying
that it's an interesting time where you
know we were all the accusations you
could just be accused of something and
that's scary scary somebody says you
were you know somebody says you're
petting their dog or something or
hugging their kids who long had a at a
Fiesta or something next thing you know
you're a bait you know that's it that's
it you know that kind of stuff I mean I
can't even a mat can you imagine say you
never did anything like that and
somebody said that put it out on
Facebook you know and I use Facebook
because that's where your neighbors see
it and how I can't even I cannot even
fathom what that would be like you know
I mean it's scary cuz they just people
then just a lot of people just connect
the dot especially the small towns
people just just you know now Facebook
is a lot of people take it all for real
so that's scary with the Roy Moore
scenario and he lost he lost to a man
Doug Jones and I think that changes
always I always think that change change
benefits in the end you know I'm not
sure how long run Moore had been in term
but it seemed like you've been in there
a while and I think Chan I think once
you said it somewhere too long you have
to get out of the seat you know it needs
to be a little bit more like musical
chairs because these people getting
awful awful comfortable you know living
off the hog you know it couldn't make it
into their mouth every time they want
but then everybody else hungry
and they sitting there to slice it right
off they are off that pigs neck writing
in their jaw but yeah so that's it man
Roy Moore is out and uh and that's the
you know that's a change and I think
that change is always good but I think
it's a scary time with these accusations
you know I feel like every guys just
waiting for that wheel to stop on them
you know who's next what does it happen
to be you know this hester prynne out
there somebody wants your job can they
just say something next thing you know
how are you gonna get fit you know
there's no it's the court of public
opinion now I mean we could shut down
the judicial system I mean it doesn't
even matter
I mean Roy Moore will probably never
even go to trial for any of those things
you know and I'm not saying if he did
those things yeah this deviant behavior
you know that's behavior that you get
the man's got to be atone for sure you
know the man's got to be wrapped up for
it's not right so it's not right it's
[ __ ] up you know but it's like can you
just say anything about anyone he could
be a hundred percent guilty I'm just
using it as an example but can you just
say anything about anyone
and what no repercussions
I mean slander it's just everything
slander now just something else going on
man something else going on how many
times have you go into a movie in his
gutter
you know they especially when it's one
of our a remake or a you know what are
your favorite franchises you loved it as
a kid you take all that nostalgia in
there with you you get there and it's
straight G to the Attar
nothing no-hitter Ninja Turtles
Baywatch Saving Private Ryan part two
did you even know they had that they
don't but you you could imagine it
couldn't you because they just they
don't care long as they can just make a
buck even if it's just a little buck
that's what they care about but that's
going to change now with a new a new
program called live tree live tree is
changing the entertainment industry
by creating a new platform called adept
adept is where the public will be able
to fund what they want to watch own what
they help produce decide who's in it and
what goes on through the process of
content creation funding and
distribution so you can check it out at
live tree dot-com I'm gonna get to a
couple of calls man they came in about
some Christmas traditions let's get into
a couple of Newfoundland yeah man that's
heavy ice white country
you got White's out there just paintin
each other white just people eating
flour people just put using chalk as
lipstick and just that's white white
white that's just white people out there
just hunt ghosts and do it hella white
stuff eating clams and I'll put on
aprons download your [ __ ] doing the most
white [ __ ] you could do that's white
country thank you for calling Andrew
onward they celebrate this Irish
tradition Christmas and it's called
mummering and we're like your host codes
or different types of things like that
so and then you go around the
neighborhood and everybody has the door
unlocked you go into people's kitchens
and you know you got a drink you have
your rum you might play a song on the
guitar and people have to guess to try
to guess who yeah from that type of
stuff and they can't see it but costumes
getting really creative you can check it
out online
mob ring huh so you dress up you put a
bag over your head you put on boots you
go around to the neighbor's house you
knock on the door you go inside somebody
plays a song and they try to guess who
you are it sounds like one of the seeds
from a Saw movie sound like somebody
about to get murked at the end of that
dude thank you good that's a good way to
lose a cousin
you showed up with a bag over your head
into a stranger's house try that in
Florida dude you try that in Florida
big daddy you bring a van full of new
fees those are people from Newfoundland
down to Florida and see how that goes
off when you show up bag headed into
people's home you're singing and dancing
do this thing in America's Got Talent
dude this floor this is st. Petersburg
gots coffins you know this is Fort
Lauderdale got Soph grave plots because
they'll start going it you know they'll
shoot you down in Florida for doing that
kind of stuff but it sounds like fun up
there I mean that sounds like definite
alcoholism things you do with the rain
when you are you're doing alcohol but
that is a Christmas tradition up there
in Newfoundland Andrew I appreciate you
sharing that with us let's take another
another call here from Blake about
Christmas down in Dallas Giovanna Blake
from Dallas and I just wanted to share a
Christmas story with you on Christmas
Eve when I was about five years old we
were and I was five years old what's as
well and I think what I remember about
it one time was the first time ever
vomited I was five and I had had be a
couple peanut butter and jellies on
raisin bran bread because my mother
loved raisin bran it's used to let us
have it and I had two of them I think
are one and a half and wanted to have
some little sandwiches even is that's
the most you can fit in a five-year-old
is one and a half sandwiches if you ever
if you feed two sandwiches to a
five-year-old you might be on that Roy
Moore dinner planned you know so the
most you could do really one and a half
sandwiches to a five-year-old and I
remember having one and a half and being
you know just excited I was so fat
laying in bed I couldn't even put my
arms by my side had to take my
underpants off that's how full of food I
was and I was feeling joyous and
something got me I think it might have
had a bad raising in the bread or
something something got up into one of
my bile ducts or something I got lodged
in my you know somewhere in my belly I
started a sour and next you know I woke
up just sat straight up and I didn't
know what was happening I mean I'd never
vomited
before knowingly and then I remember
standing on my bed I didn't know what to
do right so I stood up on my bed because
I felt like something's about to happen
I felt like a dragon was about to come
into the universe and I was gonna be his
his front door you know I was gonna be
his doorway so I just stood there
waiting for a dragon and at first I
thought I was gonna something's gonna
come out of my butt out of my ass I
guess that way you're a child it's not
really a nice really bottomless out of
my small but I thought something's gonna
come out of my small butt and instead it
just flew just projectile-vomited you
know out of my face and splattered off
the wall and I remember crying and
telling my mother that food was flying
out of me you know cuz I thought this
food had wings or something loaded it's
something crazy it happened to that you
know I don't know maybe the devil or God
didn't want me having that food or they
were you know pulling it out of my
system with invisible hands that was
something I thought all right let's hear
more thank you for calling Blake they're
over at my grandmother's sister's house
and she called all the children into a
back room and she started telling us
this she was basically talking crap
about my grandfather and she was saying
if her grandfather showed his face
around her house that she would she
would shoot him and then she reached
into her person pulled out a pistol ooh
grandma had that hit oh no she had that
peace grub all got that bullet make a
dam that's wow that's usually Bor
something like you would hear about an
Alabama over there up and up even into
North Carolina or West Virginia but I'm
too surprised to hear this behavior down
in Texas then grumble got that piece on
her let's hear more and showed us the
pistol and at that point some parent I
guess overheard what was going on or
walked into the room and you know got
all the kids out of there but that was
the Christmas the crazy aunt Janice
snapped just had to share Elan huh so I
couldn't tell there was your grandmother
yeah but somebody got that piece on them
and look dude everybody you know people
don't want to have guns around and stuff
like that I get it
you know no goods around schools I get
it no guns at busy areas I get it but
let's don't pretend that you know that
when we were young if you weren't you
know or if you're in the South Attorney
guns close to the table you know they
have guns people have guns you know I
read somewhere that there's like what
like half of a billion guns that's a lot
of guns you know I probably have a gun
somewhere right around me right now
don't even know it I mean a lot of these
guns are in between homes so there's a
lot of guns out there but I think that's
pretty brave I'm a grandmother to pull a
piece out of her purse you know I had an
ex-girlfriend I always had a piece on
her what else did one of a thicker
little one of my thicker
brother-in-law's showed up one time I'm
at the computer at midnight I'm on a
computer and he popped around the edge
of this little door this computer like
little kiosk had two doors on it and he
popped around the edge of it he got his
underpants on and he really a thicker
little kind of a gentleman kind of a
happy gentleman former male cheerleader
and he said guess how many goods I have
Oh me and B first of all do this
midnight - we don't super know each
other that great three you only have
underpants on for I don't think I've
ever even seen you without your shirt on
so to come full throttle in here no
shirt no pants no socks no socks not ask
what is that no socks bro I can
understand if you show up we don't know
each other that much you got a little
under pants and socks but under pants no
socks Wow did I feel like this dude you
know sound like his soul is on a
scavenger hunt for something you know
maybe for some [ __ ] or something wild at
night made for a couple you know kind of
score some uppers or something I'm just
on the internet I'm on Facebook and he
pop around the edge of the little
computer where the computer was this
little kind of you know wood and little
it's not an arm wall but like a little
kind of thing with doors on it I guess
how many goods that well the only has
underpaid its own so I said I don't know
because hopefully none you know
hopefully don't you have tighty whities
on in a couple of rough Bama tattoos and
he goes to do that's what he said - and
then I didn't notice now by his calf he
hadn't one of those calf holsters right
this dude has no shoes no socks no pants
calf holster going right there and then
he turned around he had a piece it is he
had like a beretta in his tighty whities
along his back Jesus man make you find
the Lord fast well he'd been he'd been
sleeping on the couch I don't even know
he's over there sleeping had two guns on
him he said I got two he goes you never
know who might come in here I said I'm
the only other person in here so if
anybody's gonna get shot it's gonna be
me man you know what the [ __ ] bro tote
it tailed take some benadryl and [ __ ]
shut it down guy guy so but I feel your
Blake family gets guns and things get
wild family gets goods and uh and things
get wild we had some of our female
callers let's hit them up here we go hey
this is Hannah I'm from the University
of North Texas down here in Denton Texas
and I'm calling in yep University of
North Texas the greedy's I think they're
called the green he's thank you for
calling Hannah you got a beautiful voice
oh thanks to the most recent podcast in
which you asked the female viewers how
they felt about the podcast and
personally I love your podcast I love it
for the reason that I actually get to
have some insight into working for the
male mind that's something I did not
grow up with yeah Thank You Hannah well
look I mean I'm just trying to figure
out how the male body male mind works
so I appreciate jiva for you know
sticking around and being involved in in
this experimentation Oh word
no brothers no male cousins and my
father he I guess wasn't very
comfortable kind of talking to me about
male nature or just the way men are in
general yeah I can imagine your father
might how - because Ben don't know how
sometimes we don't we don't know how we
you know we're still learning as we go
and the problem is by the time we think
we get an inkling the time is up usually
you know it's hard for a man sometimes
to get a perspective of himself because
I think he's too busy being a man you
know there's so much happening sometimes
when you're a man that it's hard to just
step back and get a look at everything
that's going on you know it's hard to
watch the movie when you're in it it's
hard to watch the movie when you're in
it and it's you know and it somebody's
always yelling action so it's hard to
know sometimes what the script says
there but let's hear some more Hannah
well so this podcast has been a very
valuable resource to me really the only
way that I actually get to like look
into the mind of men besides like dating
them yeah
dating a man can be dangerous could you
dating a man they trying to get you to
touch their wiener you know that's
usually part of the dating game or
they're trying to sometimes though you
know get you to play games with them
first Scrabble ride around on a truck
you know get a malt you know get aside I
get a side item or get a couple
appetizers but eventually they want men
want you to touch their crotch and
probably touch your crotch and that's
okay I mean that's part of what life is
you know that's part of how people get
to touch each other you know they
usually start with snacks but but yeah
I'm glad you're able to come here hand
and we're happy that you're here and and
thank you for being a part of the part
of the podcast and a part of the
environment over here we got another
beautiful call that came in right here
let's take another this isn't Hannah but
this is close
Saudi Arabia thank you for calling I've
never been to Saudi Arabia before I've
been at Kuwait and I've been to Iraq
thank you for calling Hannah I was Wow
so you were really the middle east of
two different two different continents
you know you really cleave gana Stan
some people call it cleave gettest an
odd word thank you for calling happy
holidays I thought as a
I might call in and just say you know we
don't celebrate Christmas but fun fact
we do love Jesus and it's fun and you
know we celebrate him for being one of
the most beloved prophets and all of
tongue and we believe that Jesus said in
the Quran and peace be upon me the day I
was born the day I die and the day I
shall be raised alive oh wow that's
beautiful I appreciate you sharing that
with us and she's saying that and in her
Muslim in her muslimah t if that if that
could be a word that that they don't
celebrate Christmas but that they do see
Jesus as as an amazing prophet let's
hear more on work surah maryam chapter
19 verse 33 if anybody wants to google
that they don't believe me we are
sharing the love all over the world for
you love what you're doing love your
spirit and thanks for creating that
content that can touch us all over the
world hope you have a great holiday a
great New Year oh it's very sweet of you
and I appreciate that and the same to
you guys
you know I probably should have looked
up and seen how to to express like a
happy new year in Muslim or but I just
haven't I did it but I something I'll
make sure to uh to check out so I can
get a little bit more information into
my brain but thank you for listening
thank you for being a part of you know a
part of this past weekend sorry guys I'm
a little out of it I mean my brain is
just slow it's hard for me to you know
my nose just keeps making noises like
it's you know it's like it's doing sign
language with sounds like every couple
seconds it'll just kind of bubble up or
it's like one of those they used to have
this show called the Snorks where it's
like this family of creatures that were
underwater they always had these bubbles
coming out of their snouts and that's
what I feel like right now I got the
bubble guts but it's up in the snout you
know it must now it's making noises like
it's a little bit of Morse code you know
but it's not really saying anything but
thank you for calling in and for sharing
Christmas wishes with us
even though Christmas is it something
that you celebrate I think that that's a
really beautiful thing to do to cross
you know to sort of cross religious
beliefs to to to express joy for
somebody else and in their holiday under
their religion so thank you that's very
sweet of you
oh we might have to shut it down so you
guys cuz I'm running out of speed we'll
get back to a regular episode of Monday
I got what we're call here though and
this is whether I wanted to get some I
wanted to get some callers in for let's
see what we could do right here to help
this young lady
okay feel it savvy in Tennessee I just
listened to this past weekend today and
I heard at the end that you don't get a
lot of female callers so I thought I
would just do the females a solid and
call my question and light issue right
now is that I feel like I put myself in
the friendzone because I'm kind of like
back and rather just like hang out with
the guys instead of the girls and like
listen to gossip and fashion and shoes
like I don't give well look I mean thank
you for calling sometimes I want to be
right there with you you know sometimes
I want to just you know just enjoy
myself and relax and talk about Scheffer
robes and talk about you know different
colors of paint you know sometimes I
don't want to always be sitting around
the fellas would be armor a sling
you know then it you know and calling
each other gays and stuff so does I want
to be doing real stuff you know exciting
things you know like learning how to do
art or do claymation or you know so I do
archery a wrassle you know sometimes I
want to do things that you know even
ladies do you know like try on different
hats or you know you know what else
dance
I mean I'm [ __ ] honestly dude I could
have been a [ __ ] good dancer you know
I got strong I got strong straight legs
let's hear more give a crap I grab fish
listen to a good fart joke or something
you know like I just I just need some
advice or your perspective
what I need to do to not be immediately
put in the friendzone because I'm too
cool or just then a guy's friend into
the female psyche so I mean in your
special you say something about like put
down the the dumbbell and pick up some
flowers and look lost
like I don't list but I don't want to
pick up flowers and loss just some guy
sweeps me off my feet like that's not me
I'm just trying to be myself but then I
feel like I care a bunch of bad away
because I'm just you know fun to hang
out with but anyway I enjoy the podcast
appreciate you man be good to yourself
because you definitely deserve it okay
oh that's sweet of you I appreciate I
appreciate you calling in there Abbi and
that's you know it's a good question you
know Abbie said the friendzone you know
you don't want to have to you know I see
you don't want to have to wear you know
put honey on your neck and you know take
pictures of your you know your crotch or
anything to your shirt or you know uh
you know stuff like that to get men to
realize you want to be more than friends
you don't have to go to those links you
want to just be able to be you but not
have guys immediately put you into the
friendzone
well some I mean for me and I'm gonna
let's do it let's do this for money
let's take some calls in on that like if
a woman's in the friendzone how can you
know as dudes like what can we do or
what can we see so that we don't think
she stays there you know like if this
were your sister asked at you guys like
how do I get out of this friendzone how
do I not be in it
you know what advice would you give or
what thoughts would you give her
suggestions you could hit the hotline
with those nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and I apologize
again for this voice you guys have been
having to listen to this whole time like
my nose I just can't I can't breathe
through it so it's I mean I feel like
I've been underwater this whole time I
can't really hear that good this has
been uh this has been a definitely
interesting I feel like I miss it a
since you know but let's see if what we
got for a because she don't want to be
out there you know she don't want to be
out there being you know having to be
like a you know showing laying
everywhere and that sort of thing
to get a man you know she don't would
have to be tying jerky around her thighs
or anything to let these men know that
she wants to you know might have more
out there instead of just friendship and
I mean I think for for me friendships a
great place to start
I mean sometimes if you're thinking
really long term it's even it can be
even more important than anything else
you know because you never really you
might you might get tired of [ __ ]
your friend but you still gonna want to
be friends with them whereas if it's
just somebody that's just sex is the
only interest you once you get tired of
[ __ ] you only have the friendship
level then there's nothing so friendship
is important so I think you wanna get
fully out of the friendzone but I
noticed even for me the simple things
with a lady where is if she got a tat if
she shows off some of that Ted you know
that that ain't work if she have a lady
guy you know she has a if she could cook
and she brings like a nice meal I know
these things might sound old-fashioned
that's fine but these I'm just telling
you things lipstick something even as
simple as lipstick you know if a girl
brings a friend of hers around and I can
see them like you know just joking and
interacting with each other that always
you know that immediately changes kind
of how I look at her as if she as
opposed to have just her by herself is
always around you know so that kind of
adjust things a little what else to get
a girl out of the friendzone I mean
don't be wearing like you know James
Harden jerseys and stuff like that I
don't think that's probably the most
solid way to go it doesn't sound like
for you you know so I think some attire
so stockings I like a little bit of
stocking you know you don't see a lot of
stockings anymore I like that stocking
what else you know I like that a little
bit of hosiery I like I like the girl I
have them a little bit of hosiery you
know they got them leg you know got
their legs wrapped up just like tall
lone gifts with these in the middle
that's what I like so those are the some
thoughts but I want to hear what our
what our with some of our constituents
think here and I want to thank you guys
for listening to this past weekend we'll
be back on Monday with a regular
episode and again I'm sorry for my voice
man I love you guys and be good to
yourselves you probably deserve it thank
you Andrew Blake for all the calls
alright and let's hear this
alright one more time on the way out
let's hear Christmas time man you're
gonna sleep barely keep my eyes open
[Music]
in a big thank you to our I want to also
thank Budd Galloway came back today we
gave but another shot here to come in
and do some team work so we're getting
the job done here tonight Thank You bud
thank you sure for the beautiful video
audio editing lovely Merry Christmas
[Music]